um es einmal vorwegzunehmen dass es eine
ganz schön komplizierte Rede für mich
draußen protestiert beides for future
jetzt spreche ich hier als Aktivistin
und als grünen Mitglied und nach meiner
Rede werde ich mit anderen zusammen nach
lützerath fahren wohin sonst
eine komplizierte Rede
eine komplizierte Rede in komplizierten
Zeiten
heute im Oktober 2022 sind die 20er also
die entscheidende Dekade des 21
jahrhunderts zu fast einem Drittel
vorbei
wir haben diesen letzten Jahren gelernt
dass das Ende der Welt im Plural kommt
das Ende der Welt ist nicht die eine
große Katastrophe es ist eine Gewissheit
nach der anderen die kollabiert Stück
für Stück
die Gewissheit dass wir jungen Menschen
es mal besser oder genauso gut haben
werden sie ist nicht mehr die Gewissheit
dass Europa immer friedlicher und die
Welt immer demokratischer wird auch
nicht
irrigiert unter den härtesten nur
vorstellbaren Bedingungen wir und ich
sehen dass es hart ist und dass ihr
kämpft
aber wir wissen auch dass es immer
härter werden wird vor allem deshalb
weil es kein Spielraum mehr gibt um
Krisen warten zu lassen aufzuschieben
allen voran die Klimakrise lässt man sie
nur eine Sekunde aus den Augen kommt sie
unmittelbar und in zehnfacher Wucht auf
uns zurück
und
während es so hart ist und so zehrend
und die Angst so groß ist vor dem was
passiert wenn das mit der Energiekrise
nicht aufgeht erlebe ich unter Grünen
einen neuen Modus eine Art ökologischen
Hyperrealismus
da wird dann erklärt dass man sich nicht
im kleinen verkämpfen soll da sättigt
man die Demokratie rundern durch lieber
noch mit einer Runde Öl von Verbrechern
damit die Gesellschaft nicht die Laune
verliert für den Klimaschutz da werden
klimafeindliche
da werden klimafeindliche Entscheidungen
so plausibel verteidigt wenn man still
ist hört man irgendwo ein Ökosystem Wein
vor Rührung
und ich frag euch aber was ist denn
Realpolitik in der Klimakatastrophe
Scholz und Lindner sie sind nicht die
Realität Friedrich Merz und sein
klimapopulismus ist es auch nicht
der Druck der Druck der rechten Medien
das clickbating das ist nicht die
Realität
Pakistan ist die Realität 100.000 Hitze
tut einer Europa das sind die Realitäten
Stürme und dörrende nie gekannten Ausmaß
das ist die Realität Hungerkrisen und
Verfolgung der Frauen der Kinder der
people of color Katastrophen für die wir
keine Worte haben das ist die Realität
[Applaus]
jeder von uns liebt jemanden der im Jahr
2100 noch leben wird sagt die
pakistanische Aktivistin Aisha die
Realität ist dass in jedem Augenblick in
dem jemand hier im Raum sagt wir machen
doch schon oder das ist doch ein guter
Schritt fürs Klima
irgendeines eurer Kinder an der eigenen
Zukunft verzweifelt
ich verstehe dass ihr die Misere der
anderen ausbadet ich verstehe dass der
Weg aus den fossilen nach dem 24 Februar
diesen Jahres ein anderer sein muss als
davor
was ich aber nicht verstehe ist dass
dieser provisorische Weg für Jahrzehnte
zementiert wird dass man neue fossile
Infrastruktur schafft die es absehbar
nicht mehr braucht was ich nicht
verstehe
was ich nicht verstehe ist dass man
Verträge unterschreibt die wieder
gebrochen werden müssen wenn man das
Pariser Abkommen nicht auch noch brechen
will was ich nicht verstehe ist das
selbst dieses Themen erschütterndsten
Krisen anscheinend nicht ausreichen um
endlich mal durchzuprobieren was denn
Systemwandel in der Umsetzung heißt was
ich nicht verstehe ist dass man in
entscheidenden Stellen immer und immer
und immer wieder die falschen die Regeln
machen lässt vor 30 Jahren vor 30 Jahren
hat meine Großmutter eine Solaranlage
auf ihrem Dach installiert da lag was in
der Luft Energiewende von unten ihr
kennt das alles 30 Jahre später Anfang
der 2020er wurde in Sachsen ein einziges
Windrad aufgestellt und Deutschlands
Energiesicherheit lag in den Händen
eines kriegstreibenden Autokraten was
ist die Botschaft aus diesem 30 Jahren
solange fossile Kräfte und fossile
Konzerne die Regeln für die Energiewende
machen wird es keine Energiewende geben
die den Namen verdient es ist eigentlich
nicht so schwer zu verstehen
es ist eigentlich nicht schwer zu
verstehen würde man meinen und jetzt
stehen wieder wieder und wir gucken auf
lützerath wir gucken auf lützerath das
Dorf dass man versucht hat als
verlorenen Kleinkrieg oder als
ideologisches Projekt zu diskreditieren
mit dem Blick immer auf das scheinbar
große Ganze dabei ist es so in litzerath
manifestiert sich das große Ganze dieses
Dorf sitzt auf Millionen Tonnen CO2 ist
eine reale Festung für unseren Bruch mit
dem Pariser Abkommen man hat gejubelt
der Kohleausstieg 2030 leute bitte
klatschen und im Deal mit RWE da würden
ja 280 Millionen Tonnen CO2 eingespart
werden welche klimaaktivistin kann das
verteufeln aber jetzt gibt es zahlen und
die stehen im Netz und die sind für alle
einsehbar und die sind eindeutig
wenn RWE die im Deal ermöglichte
Auslastung aller Kraftwerke in den 20er
Jahren nutzt dann wird durch den
vorgezogenen Kohleausstieg 2030 keine
einzige Tonne CO2 eingespart
und ich frag euch ganz ehrlich seit wann
argumentieren die Grünen mit gefakten
Zahlen von RWE seit wann
[Applaus]
280 Millionen Tonnen darf RWE laut
vereinig Vereinbarung aus dem Boden
holen keine 50 Millionen Tonnen dürften
sein für 1,5 Grad ziemlich einfache
Rechnung und ja ist ein schwierige
Zeiten sagt man dann da muss man
Kompromisse machen aber ihr wisst es
doch selbst nicht der Kompromiss stiftet
in der Klimapolitik zwangsläufig Frieden
weniger Emissionen tun es Solidarität
mit den richtigen tut es
[Applaus]
so lange kohlekonzerne die Regeln machen
gibt es keine Klimagerechtigkeit die
Regeln die muss man schon selbst machen
20 30
ist als ausstiegdatum der Anfang aber
jetzt muss die Kohle dahinter stimmen
das heißt ein Moratorium philisterat
eine kompensationslösung für die
erzeugten Emissionen und ein echter
Prozess zu Gestaltung des Tagebaus und
ja ich spreche auch von diesem crazy
absurden Vorschlag diesen Tagebau um
jeden Zwang um jeden Preis zu fluten das
muss doch das Mindeste sein das mindeste
für euch als bündnispartei als
klimapartei als Friedenspartei es muss
das Mindeste sein
Krisen krisenraum der Demokratie ihre
Substanz je mehr Krisen desto schneller
die Entscheidung aber dieser Parteitag
findet ja nun mal statt und der muss das
Korrektiv sein um die Entscheidung zu
demokratisieren und wenn nötig eben auch
zu verändern das Zeug nicht von
politischer Unsicherheit sondern von
grünem Selbstbewusstsein und sorry daran
sollte es euch wirklich nicht scheitern
wenn man sich wenn man sich all die
Baustellen anguckt die großen Fragen von
lützerath in die Welt und zurück dann
ist es verlockend und ich verstehe das
dann ist es verlockend die Hoffnung
aufzugeben man sagt der Bewegung wir
müssen jetzt hier anerkennen dass es
nicht mehr so realistisch ist die Sache
mit der Radikalen und gerechten
Klimawende und das stimmt wir müssen mit
Unsicherheiten hantieren aber eines
wissen wir ganz sicher wenn hier
irgendwas unrealistisch ist dann dass
wir in irgendeiner Form von stabiler
Demokratie Ökonomie oder europäischen
Friedensordnung leben wenn uns die
Lebensgrundlagen bei zwei drei vier Grad
um die Ohren fliegen
Realpolitik Realpolitik im 21
Jahrhundert versteht dass der der die
Realität nur für ein Augenblick
ausblendet weil der Koalitionspartner
stresst oder weiß doch einfach alles
sehr mühsam ist nicht für Befriedung
sondern zur Radikalisierung der Realität
beiträgt
und
und dabei geht es ja anders so vieles
greifbar die 100 Milliarden für
Klimaschutz können kommen und ihr seid
auf diesen Parteitag dafür historische
Schritte gegangen und es geht weiter in
den nächsten drei Jahren war es ein
Schutzwall vor der rechten anti-klima
von das heißt konkret feste
sektorenziele die so einklagbar werden
ein europäische Energiestrategie ein
cooler stieg im Osten Erneuerbaren
Lichtgeschwindigkeit endlich Maßnahmen
zur Einsparung und Suffizienz und und
und legt los und
dazu gehört auch das Klimaschutz
Sofortprogramm natürlich und ja wenn
sich die FDP weigert dann müssen die
Grünen eben eigene Vorschläge machen es
wird ja keine leichtere Zeit kommen es
wird nie weniger Krise sein oder eine
leichte Koalition der hergeflogen komme
der man sich besser einigen kann es gibt
keinen Tag zu verlieren und keine
Legislaturperiode zu verschwenden
in diesem Jahr werden die Weichen
gestellt und es liegt an euch in diesem
krisenstrudel endlich an Horizont zu
ziehen es liegt an euch in der Koalition
die ökologischen Grenzen zu ziehen und
zu verteidigen als würde es um alles
gehen denn das tut es und ich verspreche
euch wie als Bewegung werden unseren
Teil dazu beitragen Liebe
[Applaus]
Liebe grüne
egal wie hart unsere Kritik ist und wie
laut unser Protest wir entlassen euch
nicht aus der Verantwortung im Gegenteil
wir setzen auf euch in den Ministerien
im Parlament und vor Ort vor Ort dort wo
so viele von euch aktiv sind wo jetzt
mehr als je zuvor entschieden wird ob
Klimagerechtigkeit Wirklichkeit wird wir
kämpfen hier nicht weil es leicht ist
sondern weil wir wissen dass auf dem
Spektrum von vier Katastrophe und
unendlich unerträgliche Katastrophe so
unfassbar viel zu verlieren und viel
mehr noch unendlich viel zu gewinnen ist
dankeschön
[Applaus]
Liebe Luisa du hast ganz zu Beginn
gesagt dass das hier für dich keine
leichte Rede ist und ich kann sagen dass
das für mich auch keine ganz leichte
wiederung ist denn du hast vieles gesagt
was uns zum Nachdenken anregen muss du
hast auch Frust geäußert du hast vieles
gesagt woran wir zusammen arbeiten
müssen und mir fällt es auch nicht so
leicht darauf zu erwidern und ich glaube
vielen von uns fällt es auch nicht
leicht diese Worte zu hören und ehrlich
gesagt haben wir natürlich auch davor
darüber nach Verdacht nennt man Luisa
Neubauer zu diesen Parteitag ein lernt
man sie ein in einer Zeit wo man weiß
dass du hier keine Rede halten wirst wie
sagt die Grünen sind die tollste Partei
jemals super Regierungsarbeit vielen
Dank sondern wo man weiß dass Kritik
kommt wo man auch weiß dass das Einfluss
auf Abstimmung haben kann die wir heute
hier führen und wir haben uns
entschieden das zu tun und wir haben uns
entschieden weil aus meiner Sicht eines
Glas sein muss wenn wir die Klimakrise
bezwingen wollen wenn wir gute grüne
Regierungspolitik machen wollen
bündnispartei das ist man nicht nur in
der Opposition
bündnispartei ist man gerade dort wo es
Kritik gibt bündnispartei ist man gerade
dort wo man regiert wo man Verantwortung
übernimmt bündnisparteis man gerade auch
dort wo es weh tut
und du hast auch viele Punkte
angesprochen ich will nicht auf die
einzelnen Punkte das wäre gemein für die
Debatte später wo es noch viele
Redebeiträge gibt und wo auch ich noch
mal was sagen werde wir beide standen
mal ganz zu Beginn wo wir uns
kennengelernt haben 2018 vom Deutschen
Bundestag und ich war als grüne
Jugendsprecherin dort auf der ersten
Demo von Fridays for future du warst
damals als Gründerin hier mit in
Deutschland von Fridays for future und
seitdem haben sich unsere Rollen sehr
verändert wir sind nicht die gleichen
Wege gegangen ist ein unterschiedliche
Wege gegangen und wir haben heute
unterschiedliche Rollen und ich glaube
das ist wichtig ist dass wir uns diese
unterschiedlichen Rollen zugestehen dass
ihr das bei uns tut dass wir das aber
auch bei euch tun und dass wir trotzdem
in diesen unterschiedlichen Rollen
zusammenarbeiten und ja dabei wird es
immer wieder auch Momente geben wo wir
euch enttäuschen werden dabei wird es
Momente geben wo wir sagen werden wenn
die Entscheidung ist inzwischen etwas zu
tun was nicht perfekt ist und gar nichts
zu tun dann werden wir uns für die nicht
perfekte Lösung entscheiden und das wird
euch nicht immer gefallen und das werden
wir wissen aber ich verspreche dir auch
und ich glaube dieser Parteitag ist
heute ein Zeichen dafür wir werden immer
wieder kämpfen dafür noch mehr
rauszuholen wir werden auch als Partei
uns dafür einsetzen in der Regierung
mehr rauszuholen als bisher drin war und
in diesem Sinne werden wir heute mit
diesen Beschluss gemeinsam beschließen
eine Forderung die von dir kam und
vielen Verbündeten dass wir als Grüne
Partei und dafür einsetzen dass es nicht
nur ein Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr gibt sondern dass es jetzt
100 Milliarden gibt für Klimaschutz und
Effizienz 100 Milliarden für unsere
Zukunft vielen Dank dass du da bist
Luisa